let me ask on the morality side in the
books that I mentioned God Delusion I'll
go on God you described the human beings
don't need religion to be moral
so from an engineering perspective we
want to engineer morality into AI
systems so in general where do you think
morals come from in humans a very
complicated and interesting question
it's clear to me that the moral
standards the moral values of our
civilization changes as the decades go
by certainly as the centuries go by even
as the decades go by and we in the 21st
century are quite clearly labeled 21st
century people in terms of our moral
values we there's a spread I mean some
of us are a little bit more ruthless a
much more conservative some of us more
more liberal and so on but we all
subscribe to pretty much the same views
when you compare us with say 18th
century 17th century people even 19th
century 20th century people so we're
much less racist or a much less sexist
and so on than we used to be some some
people are still racist in some store
sexist but the the spreads have shifted
that the Gaussian distribution has moved
and moves steadily as the centuries go
by and that is the most powerful
influence I can see on our moral values
and that doesn't have anything to do
with religion I mean the religion of the
these are the morals of the Old
Testament our Bronze Age models morals
they're deplorable and they are to be
understood in terms of the people in in
the desert who made them up at the time
and so human sacrifice an eye for an eye
a tooth for a tooth petty revenge
killing people for breaking the Sabbath
all that kind of thing
inconceivable now so at some point
religious texts may have in part
reflected that Gaussian distribution at
that time I did I'm sure they always
reflect that yes and then now but the
the sort of almost like the meme as you
described it of ideas moves much faster
than religious to annually yes so basing
your morals on on religious texts which
were written millennia ago um it is not
a great way to proceed I think that's
pretty clear so not only should we not
get our morals from such text but we
don't quite clearly don't um if we did
then we would be discriminating against
women and we'd be racist we'd be killing
homosexuals and so on so so we don't and
we shouldn't now of course it's possible
to buy the to use yours 21st century
standards of morality and you can look
at the Bible and you can cherry-pick
particular verses which conform to our
modern morality and you'll find that
Jesus says some pretty nice things which
is great but you're using your 21st
century morality to decide which verses
to pick which verses to reject and so
why not cut out the middleman of the
Bible and go straight to the 21st
century morality which is where that
comes from is a much more complicated
question why is it that morality moral
values change as the centuries go by
they undoubtedly do and is a very
interesting question to ask why it's
another example of cultural evolution
just as technology progresses so moral
values progress for probably very
different reasons but if the it's
interesting if the direction in which
that progress is happening has some
evolutionary value or if it's merely a
drift that can go into any direction no
choice any direction and I'm not sure
evolutionarily valuable what it is is
progressive in the sense that each step
is a step in the same direction as the
previous step so it becomes more general
more decent as by modern standards more
liberal
less violent see but more decent I think
you're using terms and interpreting
everything in the context of the 21st
century yeah because Genghis Khan will
probably say that this is not more
decent because we're now you know
there's a lot of weak members of society
we're not murdering yes and I was
careful to say bye-bye the stance the
21st century by up by our standards if
we with hindsight look back at history
what we see is a trend in the direction
towards us towards our present right a
present for us we see progress but it's
it's an open question whether that won't
you know I don't see necessarily why we
can never return to Genghis Khan test we
could I suspect we won't but it but if
you look at the history of moral values
over the centuries it is in a
progressive I use the word progressive
not in a value judgment sense in the
sense of of a transitive sense each step
is the same is the same direction of the
previous step so things like we don't
derive entertainment from torturing cats
we don't derive entertainment from from
like the Romans did in the Coliseum from
from that state rather or rather we
suppress the desire to get I mean to
have play
it's probably in us somewhere so there's
a bunch of parts of our brain one
they're probably you know limbic system
that wants certain pleasures and that's
I didn't I mean I I wouldn't have said
that but your Liberty to think that life
well good there's a there's a den Carlin
of hardcore history there's a really
nice explanation of how we've enjoyed
watching the torture of people the
fighting of people just the torture the
suffering of people throughout history
as entertainment until quite recently
and now everything we do with sports
we're kind of channeling that yelling
into something else I mean there there
is some dark aspects of human nature
there are underneath everything and I do
hope this like higher level software
we've built will keep us at bay yes I'm
also
and have history with the Soviet Union
in the Holocaust and I clearly remember
that some of the darker aspects of human
nature creeped out there they do that
there have been there have been steps
back was 200 admittedly and and the
Holocaust is obvious one but if you take
a broad view of history it's it's in the
same direction
you